no surprise here Carrie Underwood  totally steals the CMT Awards red carpet  [Music]  the blonde beauty served up some serious  bling bling in this embellished number  check it out from head to toe  glitzy drop earrings a crystal beaded  top a shimmering iridescent skirt a  sparkly clutch strappy metallic heels  the perfect ensemble to compliment  carries killer legs  [Music]  we'll check it  Carrie took to the stage with Keith  Urban to perform their hit the fighter  and completely switched up her look  black leather leggings and a waterfall  ruffled top two incredible outfits which  one was your favorite tweet us at ET now  [Music]